at this altitude this episode is brought
to you by wealthfront and this is a very
unique sponsor wealthfront is a
massively disruptive in a good way set
it and forget it investing service led
by technologists from places like Apple
and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront dot-com forward
slash tim take the risk assessment quiz
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why
the value of wealth front is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than ten asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealth front as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15 thousand which is managed
for free if you use my link wealthfront
com forward slash Tim that is less than
five dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance
now normally when I have a sponsor on
the show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get $15,000 managed for
free if you decide to open an account
but just start with seeing the portfolio
that they would suggest for you take two
minutes fill out their questionnaire at
wealthfront dot-com forward slash Tim
it's fast it's free there's no downside
that I can think of this episode is
brought to you by 99designs when your
business needs a logo website business
card thumbnail or any other design I
recommend checking out 99 designs I use
them myself I've used them for many
years I use them to create book cover
prototypes for the 4-hour body which
went on to becoming number one New York
Times best seller I've also used them
for banner ads illustrations and much
more with 99 designs you get a variety
of original designs from designers
around the world give your feedback and
then pick your favorite your happiness
is guaranteed so check out some of my
competitions and designs and some of
your competitions and designs from
fellow Tim Ferriss shell listeners at
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim and
right now you can get a free and $99
upgrade on your first design so check it
out 99 designs dot-com forward slash Tim
hello poodles and parakeets or maybe you
prefer polar-bear if you're a tough guy
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
please excuse my irreverence I've had
way too much coffee and that is my dog
attempting to do breakdancing sorry for
the background noise this episode like
all episodes of the Tim Ferriss show
includes a dose of deconstructing
someone who is a world-class performer
and exceptionally good at what they do
in this case we have a science writer
but the other half of this show quite
frankly is purely selfish it is me
exploring subjects that I want to know
more about and in this case the guest is
not a military strategist not an
entertainer it is Eric Vance
Eric with a ke you can say hi to him on
Twitter at Eric Vance he is an
award-winning science writer based in
California and Mexico City after working
as a scientist on research projects
dealing with dolphin intelligence and
coastal ecology he became an educator
and then later an environmental
consultant in 2005 he switched gears and
attended UC Santa Cruz famed science
communication program great program I
almost went to UC Santa Cruz for fiction
in fact and discovered a passion for
journalism since then he has built his
career around science-based profiles of
inspiring or controversial figures I
mean we dig into not only the science
but also his approach to writing and
conveying that his work has appeared in
Harper's Magazine the New York Times
Scientific American National Geographic
he's also contributing editor at
Discover Magazine and his latest book is
suggestible you the curious science of
your brains ability to deceive transform
and heal in this episode we cover many
topics with equal amounts of the
profound actionable and hilarious we're
talking about the power of placebo and
how you can increase the odds of it
working for you if you so choose which
conditions respond well to placebo for
instance depression Parkinson's and
which do not how the mind religion
bedside manner and peer pressure can
dramatically influence medical outcomes
and then we get to some stories and not
necessarily in that order
catching porcupines in South Africa this
story alone is worth the time it takes
to listen to this episode it'll make you
laugh out loud it's awesome
finding and studying a pigshit sommelier
yes you heard me correctly why he got
electrocuted for half an hour at the NIH
laboratories in Bethesda Maryland the
story of why he chose to be cursed by a
witch doctor in Mexico City and much
much more
so please enjoy a conversation that I
very much enjoyed with Eric Vance and as
always you can find all links to
everything mentioned in this episode in
the show notes for this episode and
every other episode at 4-hour workweek
dot-com all spelled out for our workweek
com forward slash podcast Eric welcome
to the show thanks for having me done I
appreciate it of course and where does
this find you at the moment I am
currently in my office in Mexico City
and the Roma if anyone's ever been to
Mexico City where I'm based in the DfE
and how did it yeah how did you end up
in Mexico City
actually my I told my wife years ago
that I'm a freelance journalist that I I
can live anywhere in the world and and
and you know I wanted to travel with her
and she works in development and and she
came back and told me Mexico City is
where she got a job and I I said I kind
of meant like Paris or Venice you know
anywhere in the world you know like one
didn't but we came down here and I fell
in love with it and so I loved it it's
an amazing city great food from what I'm
here I've never been but hardly
incredible food and you've traveled
you've traveled a lot you've spent time
all over the planet and what I'd like to
start with perhaps is why biology how
did interested in biology and then we'll
talk about some of the adventures that
then relate to that but how the initial
interest you know when I was a kid I was
never all that good in school I didn't I
had some some attention issues and I you
know when I was in issues attention so
attention got it
pay attention real well and but like
when I was out of school like I spent a
lot of time like walking through the
woods basically looking for
dead things and then sort of poking him
and opening him up and stuff
and I didn't realize this was a field
like this it wasn't until later even
when I'd gone through biology classes I
didn't I realized that that's what we
were talking about till I really got the
just before college when I realized that
you know poking dead things and finding
them is is actually something people do
for a living and I was hooked at that
point and what did the trajectory look
like I mean did you go immediately as
soon as you got into undergrad into the
sciences I did I got I got really hooked
as an undergrad in the field biology
there's there's two kinds of biology
there's uh there's microscope biology
and binoculars biology and I got in the
binoculars biology yeah chasing after
animals and stuff like that and looking
at trees and I loved it and I and I
really wanted to be a scientist I wanted
to be you know be a PhD and and and you
know published papers I just wasn't that
good at it I you know I loved wandering
and learning new things but doing the
actual work was not my forte and so I
went through a bit of a crisis and
backed away from biology and discovered
journalism and specifically science
journalism and that's where I really
found my growth how old were you when
that happened when you took that fork in
the road I was 27 I think I spent a
solid five years after college being a
sort of a biologist for hire and working
in some laboratories around the world
and doing some different things it's
never really you know logging in I kept
jumping from one thing to the next and I
was about 27 when I finally discovered
science writing and went back to grad
school for fir for journalism how did
you make that decision in the sense that
and I also realized I accidentally used
a Yogi Berra quote when you took that
fork in the road that's not reach a fork
in the road take it that's not proper
English folks I need more caffeine but
what was the moment in which you decided
that you were going to bite the bullet
so to speak and and pursue that I mean
was it a particular conversation a
particular dinner
you know I always had I always had this
sort of scientific like sense of like
superiority to writers and I always
thought writers were kind of a bore and
and yet I had written a novel that will
never be published and never should be
published as as a scientist and I just
love writing but I just didn't like like
there's something about you know that
that process I just couldn't admit that
I actually liked you know it was like
this I know I'm a scientist I'm
analytical and and yet I'm doing all
that stuff on the side and finally it
was really a matter of a single Google
search after doing some soul-searching
where I typed in science and writing
into a Google search and lo and behold I
found out there's a whole you know a
whole career for science writers I'd
never really thought of and when I was a
kid I used to get these little things
called zoo books they're these little
you know magazines that you get it was
like your first male you ever got me or
a kid and I was letting I have the
animals you learn about the animals I
always wanted to be the guy who was like
in the magazine like you know pulling
apart you know sharks or you know
picking up an answer new stuff and when
I will realize in that moment was I
don't want to be the guy in the magazine
I want to be the guy making the magazine
like it was the magazine that I really
loved it wasn't you know every every
month it was something new and and
that's what I liked and that like
clicked and then I was off now you
although you went on the the other side
of the camera so to speak to to document
an interview and research you've also
spent a fair amount of time in the field
so and I don't know the answer this
question but which came first the the
pig [ __ ] or the porcupines the
porcupines came before the pig okay can
you explain the porcupines please well
right so in my process of becoming of
trying to be a scientist one of the
places I went was in South Africa and I
basically I needed I needed a subject
for my PhD and so I just figure I go to
South Africa and like catch sharks and
do cool stuff and figure out what I was
all about and why South
I had seen the movie the power of one
and I really liked it I thought it was
good and so I said if that's what I'm
going yes and that was literally as much
thought as I put into it like I was I
was in the 88 as a kid and so and I
actually tried to reenact I'd go like
through these slums of South Africa go
jogging and stuff thinking that children
are like chase me and I just had people
be like dude you shouldn't be here Oh
get hurt so but I did wandering around
and I ended up hooking up with this
laboratory at Cape Town University Cape
Town and sometimes they farmed out their
scientists to to to like documentaries
and so I was still a scientist at that
point but there was a documentary the
BBC was doing a program on aardvarks and
the animals that live in their burrows
so it was really exciting stuff like a
thriller yeah oh yeah I mean they had
you know they had art wolves and and and
a bunch of other animals that live in
these burrows and one of them was
porcupine so with the need is any of the
biologists to go in and catch the
porcupines and habituate them that was
the deal and say hey you know he and you
know they got this lame kid sort of
wandering around their lab who they were
like okay let's just send him cuz he's
not really doing anything and so he sent
me into the bush for ten days with with
some really interesting characters I
mean the people who end up you know
signing up for this or you know a
diverse group and it was one the guy
who's leading the expedition was sort of
this guy who'd spent a lot of time in
the bush and was just was savvy but
really quiet didn't say anything and
he'd sort of occasionally catch birds
with his bare hands like a praying
mantis although a very large one yeah he
was like walking for the car and there'd
be this bird you know like sort of you
know crouched and he just like snap out
and grab it and then and then there were
just other dude who was come who was in
the in the field to detox from his
heroin addiction and he was a
it was a former Satan worshipper who'd
become a born-again Christian and I
learned that it's not actually that
different actually you think he's like
he didn't actually change much he just
sort of switched sides you know he was
just before he'd say you know I can feel
the claws of Satan like ripping into my
chest and parting the skin in my chest
and and now it's a bad thing before it
was like it was like a massage and he
was really intense you know he was still
totally focused on Satan as a born-again
Christian which I had never thought
about before but it is a big thing and
and he was just this really interesting
guy who sort of me and him and this guy
who never spoke and and so we sort of
spent our days smoking cigarettes and
the the recovering addict was would like
try to catch fish with a stick and a
hook that he had found and we'd go out
with the giant truck and this and this
this light is the like like rifle
looking like flashlights and look for
look for porcupines and and I learned a
few things about porcupines we were not
prepared it was day three before someone
suggested we get some fluff she a big
blanket but he forgot the packing list
it wasn't that we they forgot them
we just never occur that we might want
gloves occupying guys they call the
professionals this is who this is who
they send and and so I mean a so quick
thing about it porcupine so we actually
learned there were sort of like two
primary defense strategies the
porcupines have not surprising to anyone
one of them the surprising one I suppose
was that direction really fast
especially when you've been smoking
cigarettes all day yeah when they
started to run just like this one's
running and and you know they know where
their burrow is you don't and so you
know your have we spent a lot of time
just sort of
like tripping over you know over rocks
and stuff and like with our hands on our
knees sort of like just catching our
breath and having been dusted by some
fat little porcupine so that was the
first technique the second one was more
usable which was when they they just
stick their head against a tree put up
their their quills and go like you know
yeah give your best shot a saw like yeah
you know you know go ahead you know like
you know and those are the ones we want
it could we have a little syringe of
ketamine which was endlessly fascinating
to the recovering addict shamelessly
fascinating to a lot of people it's
looking family yes yeah it's actually
very useful for tranquilizing these
animals so uh but what's interesting
what I didn't realize actually every
time when you watch you know a nature
film about you know animals like a
porcupine like they didn't just stumble
upon that animal and like not our
filming that's not the way it works like
someone went out beforehand and prepped
the whole scene and and one of the ways
they they have to prep it is you catch
the animal you drugged it and then you
you have to put a put a tracking device
inside of it
because the the you know people on
watching TV don't want to see a radio
collar you don't see a pinko poor Harvey
collar around the wild porcupine yeah I
mean it's not great it's not great it's
not great for porcupine because he has
to go through basic surgery but so we
did that with this one porcupine that
they they named uncle Eric and I I never
really was clear whether that was a they
were making fun of me or it was an honor
of me really could've got other ways but
so we you know we did that and then and
then we released uncle Eric you know it
sort of back in the wild like his worms
and and then what the next step is to
hibbett weight them and so basically a
[ __ ] ooh a shoe like one step down from
taming you basically hang out with the
porcupine or whatever animal for hours
and hours and hours until they realize
that you're not going to hurt them and
they understand that you
going to feed them so they just ignore
you like you're just another tree or
whatever in that you know in their
environment and they just go about their
business
and that's when you bring in the film
crew so it's not at all like a natural
setting but you might wonder like how do
you how do you do that you know and
basically just have to talk to it for
hours and hours on end you just have to
do have to get used to the human voice
because when people come in but film
they'll be talking so so I sat out in
the middle of the you know the classic
like empty Savannah with you know the
huge sky and you know scorpions crawling
over my feet and and just talked to this
this porcupine and you know what do you
tell her book uncle Eric uncle Eric and
me hanging out together and it was I
think it was like me and it's porcupine
and what are you talking about well you
talk to him about your relationship
problems and I was sitting there you
know being like you know and then she
told me if she want me to come because
her friend was coming but I don't know
her friend and and and then a couple
years okay let me go back a couple years
you know the porcupine sitting there you
know listening to me like [ __ ]
endlessly
about this and you know the world mind
doing not sitting on a rock smoking a
cigarette listening I'm guessing against
a tree thank you dude attack me or leave
I can't do this forever forever like
what is this and remember one night I
heard the storm coming so I said go up
in a little Ridge and look at and I said
okay an hour so far it comes now he come
back and then uncle Eric's gone I'm like
okay like dang it so I grab my my
tracking license flip it on and he's not
popping up on the scanner at all and
this thing has like a hundred-yard
radius so he basically cleared a hundred
yards in like less than a minute just
did away from it as soon as I turn my
back on it it was like you know done I'm
gone he just bolted for the horizon and
and I remember just like and that was
one of the moments where I really was
wondering if I was in the right career
or not
so that so that was on the fueled
biology side I like the the binoculars
versus microscopes actually the last
interviewee or the last few folks I had
on the interviewer were on the opposite
end of the spectrum so they were
actually focused on things like the
mechanistic target of rapamycin and
looking at em trout and all this cool
stuff the so the fuel biology if we then
flash-forward right you are learning
more about science right and what was
the program that you were in it was the
actually the Santa Cruz University
California Santa Cruz science writing
program which really changed my life
it's amazing program who or what lessons
had the biggest impact on you through
that course um very program I should say
god there's so many I mean the biggest
thing is as a scientist you're trying to
be exact you need to be precise and as a
as a storyteller you need to convey a
feeling and a sense because people don't
walk away people don't read journalism
or you know storytelling the same way
that they read a scientific paper and
you know you walk away with kind of an
idea a couple little facts and I idea
and you really have to shift your
thinking to tell you know a story to
someone you have to have characters you
have to have an arc and that's really
hard and that that's something I think I
learned there but I'm constantly trying
to to perfect because it's it's a
totally different way I mean aside from
all the little things like no one using
the passive tense and you know and and
the technical jargon all the kinds of
you know it's really about you know
telling a story and it's not about
conveying information or it's about
wrapping the information in this
sugar-coated delight right call the
story so that you actually absorb it
yeah what who are some well I guess I
have so many questions just because I've
I just finished a book myself so writing
is on the brain
what about your writing besides say
using the passive tense les improve to
the most before and after going into the
program coming out of the program so and
the reason I ask is I can think of for
instance in my own history going back to
a class that I took with John McPhee
which was called the literature of fact
and what he really burned into my brain
and of course I won't even approach 10%
of the writer he is ever but was it was
how visually he thinks of structure and
it would almost speck it out on on a
blackboard or a whiteboard like a
football play it was really fascinating
or even like a Krebs cycle or something
it was very very visual and I'd never
thought of architecting something out
that way so that was a novel idea that I
still rely on sometimes when I am stuck
right when I can't figure out how to
structure story that's something that
I'll still do is are there any tools or
any particular changes that you
experienced in your own writing yeah
that's a really good one have you ever
heard of the open notebook no I haven't
I should check it out it's a it's a
website run by some really good science
writers that that's for science writers
and they have a session that section
that's just that it's basically science
writers doing schematics of stories that
how cool and their favorite stories
awesome it's great I did I did one where
I actually like tried to sketch out
burkhart builders a New Yorker story did
on on youth cowboy a youth rodeo
programs is amazing story and I just
loved it and so I tried to sketch it out
and I just guess not one of my own and
I'd love it it's very visual it's very
cool and whose so you so it's people
taking a stab at other authors or other
writers work in addition to their own
and it isn't their own yeah exactly so
it's both great experience there's a
reader and it's your experience as a
writer and of course I liked his stories
better than the one I did
looks a lot better but it's very it's
very you'd like it if there's a bunch of
other gems in there too
but the thing that I think I really took
away and I wasn't expecting from that
program was a love of characters of the
people you know like a tell a story
about you know the porcupines it's just
a weird thing you know but it's like you
tell biologists a story and they're like
yeah okay whatever like of course that's
our job
you know they're weird people doing a
weird job and that's what I really fell
in love with was the people who do it
and and and how they approach it and so
I loved for the first couple years of my
career I just wrote profiles about
amazing scientists who I thought were
doing cool stuff and and that's really
that's really what I focused on was sort
of like who are these people who are
interesting but also can tell a broader
story like you know I I have something I
want to say about you know you know gene
therapy or or you know or chemicals in
the atmosphere that that sort of vias
fall organic compounds and that changed
the atmosphere over forests I want to
tell my story but I really want to tell
it through a person you know like who is
that person you can tell that story and
what's their life like what do they
think about and why are they sitting on
top of a tree like trying to get these
air samples like how they end up there
and that's what I really found love with
programs was the people like how do you
bring a person how do you tell a story
through a person who is that and it's
not always the easiest person to find
sometimes they're the ones you're not
looking for so that's that's the best
tea up I could imagine for my next
question which is this I should point
out I mean these are all new things to
me I don't know the answers to these
questions the first reporting assignment
you sent me a little note was with a guy
who studies the smell of pig ship for a
living so probably not sort of the the
Mickey Mantle you were looking for fort
Angeles how did that come to be and walk
me through that you graduate from your
program
had you from there to this assignment
well I am you know you're young
freelance right or no one home cares
what you think or what you want to write
about you of course you know I want to
write about like sharks and you know
important stuff they're like yeah get in
line pal yeah well look at your pitch
yeah definitely you know have to come up
with you know stuff they don't have you
know and one of those things is
chemistry like not a lot of people
covering chemistry so I'll do some
chemistry and so it actually started I
was working at the Chronicle of Higher
Education and I got this where was that
The Chronicle of Higher Education in
Washington DC it's a magazine that like
in unless you're it's like highly
respected among universities and no one
else is heard of it it was actually
really great great outlet baby great
science writing so it was sort of my my
opportunity to really dig in and do cool
stories but one of those stories that
wasn't that cool this is sort of a side
300-word blurb about the chemical
involved in your herd of ladybug paint I
mean that pulls up an incredible image
in my head I'm pretty sure it's not
accurate so no I'm gonna say I had the
greatest title for the story they
wouldn't let me use but okay so now I
have to ask what is what was the what
was the headline stinky ladybug taint
that could be your punk rock band right
so okay so no I don't know it lady but
like ladybug taint is what if you're
crushing a bunch you're from the Bay
Area right I am well I live in the Bay
Area you live in a Barry
well if your question of a bunch of
grapes in like a you know classic sort
of wine crush it's inevitable that you
get one or two ladybugs and it just
happens and what happens is if you get
like one ladybug in a you know a big fat
you kind of get this nice little bell
pepper taste it's like this this this
it's this nice sort of hint in the
background if you get two or three it
gets overpowering and it just ruins the
whole batch and it's collated but must
be hard as hell to deal with I mean
right ladybugs I don't know how many
people listening have been in
I had a wine vet but those things are
gigantic I mean wow okay listen you
can't and you can't like drop a ladybug
and you don't know if there's already
one in there so I mean apparently it's a
big thing anyway
what's interesting is I was talking to
scientists who like discover the
chemical that that does this an
extremely potent powerful chemical I
think I calculated it if you took an
Olympic sized swimming pool and you put
a teaspoon in there you still be able to
taste it like this stuff is brutal sigh
sharks are the blood what humans are the
ladybug daintiness
the shark smelled this he'd be the same
way be like damn like no no no anyway
it's potent and so I started talking
this guy the way no the way I do and I
was like wow this is a weird job like
how did you find these like oh yeah
there's some ladybugs my windowsill and
shook them up in a jar and it smelled
this thing and if you ever eat a ladybug
which I'm I don't Tim have you eaten any
ladybugs ah no I've eaten a lot of
crickets but no ladybugs and my
repertoire maybe there's a reason why
you don't because and that's the reason
why they're red and black it's a warning
sign because they have this chemical and
they will unleash it if you try to eat
them and that's what it's for
so he you know he smelled this thing
he's like oh my god I got a pharaoh this
is so I asked him of course you know
what's your job that you do this he said
well I mean I don't actually study
ladybugs I actually study pig [ __ ] he
didn't say it like that but that's what
went through my head and and I was like
wait and he he specifically focuses on
smells and and these like strong smells
and make the chemicals that are involved
and what we smell and so I was like oh
my god wait so you study you know pig
manure that you study the smell of pig
manure yeah I mean you know the aerosol
you know chemical nature yeah they had a
great way to sort of say I study smelly
pig [ __ ] and I was oh my god I have to
come on meet you you know I have to like
see your laboratory this is amazing and
so I am so I pitched nature which is a
very prestigious journal it also does a
lot of science journalism I was like you
have to please let me send you know I've
done a little work for them before and
please keep send me out to talk this guy
and they were like I yeah he's an AIA
one they are you know you got a couple
hundred dollars like go out there come
back yeah get the story it's the first
time I've ever had had to head it like
you know
been on assignment to do like a story
like that I was very excited and it was
the most amazing lab I've ever seen no
no hold on what did these so this was
was this your first kind of pitch for a
remote assignment yes okay what what did
the did you do it via letter or email or
was it via phone the when you when you
were like hey boss or hey editor I said
I mean I put together a nice like email
you know like with all the pieces of the
pictures to have and it was you know and
it was like fascinating jobs night sort
cages around people who have interesting
jobs and and tried to keep the poop
humor to a minimum though I did get the
word poop in the journal nature and
that's that I want that's a way that's
okay
so you see you fly out to Iowa so fly
had I was actually have flew it to
Nebraska said I didn't I didn't actually
know the difference between the two
renting a car and driving to Iowa
because I you know I'm so nervous I was
when I was booking tickets
so I fly and I get out of the car and
you can smell it it seems to get out so
that you can actually smell it's a
phenol a specific it's often called up
by people who are into this world it's
called band-aid or farmyard and it's the
first thing you smell when you know
there's a barnyard nearby it's a it has
a high sorry very low vapor pressure so
it sticks to anything it touches which
mean a little bit of like dust in the
air and and and it'll stick to it and
you'll it's the first thing you smell it
smells a little like a band-aid and it's
like oh there must be a farm nearby that
one mm-hmm so that's what you know I
smell as soon as you get out it's a very
agricultural area I was up in Ames and I
go in this guy's lab and he just
introduces me to there's a world of
smells like that he's got like
everyone's getting smelly pens and he
has all the students like smelling the
pens to try it with their eyes closed
right you know like really hone their
ability to recognize smells that are
hidden and he's got this device called
the let's find you this
multi-dimensional gas chromatography
mass spec effect ometer you got all
right oh yeah you know I'm looking at
one right now next
this is amazing she put like let's go
back to wine right you pour some wine in
this thing right and then what it does
is it basically gas chromatography cuts
the wine up into different pieces into
different chemical components and it
breaks them up pushes them aside from
each other and starts giving them to you
one at a time for a little cup that goes
over your nose at the same time you have
a mass spec giving you a layout of what
these things are so you're smelling it
the computer is analyzing it and
together you can find stuff that no
one's found before
mm-hmm because our noses are incredibly
incredibly sensitive and so like he does
this but and he does this with wine and
that's like for practicing for some
other things but mostly he focuses on
pig [ __ ] like that's his bread and
butter and he studies like these
chemicals that make fake [ __ ] like
really really bad and he's looking for
some subtle differences you know the
song of you know of that that one big
dropping that just you know that that's
gonna solve it and he's trying to
diminish that smell I was gonna ask is
he I assume he's not making perfume I
mean so so now why is it important to
diminish the smell of pig [ __ ] well I
mean this end to your point like iske
has kind of knows he could be making
perfumes like he's incredibly sensitive
but he's doing this because the idea is
if you can change the food that a pig
eats that in order to change what comes
out from the other end then you can
diminish the smell of a pig farm and
that's actually the biggest obstacle and
in building you pick for zoning and
neighbors and so on or anything like
that yeah exactly yeah not just you know
for a whole communities that don't want
these things nearby and if you can
diminish that well maybe you can book
more than closer you can build more you
can put more pigs in them there's all
kinds of opportunities that come up once
you can sort of give the pig what it
needs without having to get like the
work chemicals and some of these
chemicals like with the ladybug really
really subtle like they're really small
so so he that's what he does and he and
he's got this device and he hooked me up
to it and he was worried that wouldn't
be able to get all the all the nuance so
rather than leaving that the sample and
the Big Shot inferred
a couple minutes 10 minutes ago what'd
he do he left it in overnight so it
really was but he stuck this thing on my
nose I would say the first couple things
you smell are actually interesting
things because it's broken up into
pieces and there's you know there's some
nice things and picture there's you know
wet cardboard and taco shell and
mushroom all these great snot all these
things you think are really obnoxious
Valley wines because those are real
chemicals and they actually you can
smell them separately oh this is great
you know I'm just imagining saying to
date like he's smell wonderful he's like
wet cardboard and mushrooms
yeah and yeah and and you don't know
until you smell you're like oh my god
that totally is my report and there's no
I mean the pigs have been eating
cardboard it's just the same chemical
and then we keep the sulfates and man
that's the business end of they shed oh
I felt like I was getting like run over
by a manure truck and you know had my
like face down one of those those uh you
know porta-potties for like it was just
horrible and as I mentioned these things
have a low vapor pressure so they stick
to where they touch that's horrible the
inside of your nose meaning for the next
three days everything I ate everything I
smell have a hint of of pig sphincter
taint exactly what you see turn in that
piece what was was there any turn of
phrase or portion of that piece that you
were proudest of when you turned it in
yeah I you know that's the the great
thing about this job is you if you read
my stories you don't get a really good a
fraction of the experience that you know
that or any any story any science writer
or really any journalist you know you
only get a fraction of the experience
that they had when that reporting that
story and this it's so rich and I wish
there were more ways to share these
things but the part that I really
enjoyed the most was this this gentleman
had he was a very very sensitive nose
and he he was able to if
you fart he could he could tell you what
you of what you ate as a great party
trick it is a project and his wife
thought his wife won and she was really
wonderful woman and started she was born
in Iowa met him in Alaska near the
mountain climber and then ended up
moving back to Iowa at his very
interesting career and and she just had
a great sense of humor about the whole
thing and she doesn't have told me that
and I also talked about how he used to
smell when she first met him he's a
mountain climber and it smells great and
you know this is different reality we
all gotta grow up someday I guess that
you mentioned you mentioned the former
Satan worshipper turned evangelical
earlier.i
you are a scientist turned journalist
but you were raised Christian Scientist
is that right or was it more your one of
your parents or both Tim you just
compared Satan worshipping to the
society no but I think that that's
probably what the Internet's gonna say
no I was I was trying to do a clumsy
transition with the theme of religion
which didn't really work out which is
why I usually avoid talking about
religion but busting my balls is fine I
did I grew up in Christian Science and
and actually I mean I I didn't really
realize it was all that weird you know
you get older and you start thinking
back on your childhood but I didn't go
to a doctor till I was 18 years old
let's think the first time and I
remember being bewildered by the whole
thing and so so it was but it was you
know Kristin Sciences is really weird
sort of interesting philosophy that's
also it's also a religion but it's it's
a thing that people don't often think
about because they've really they're not
as many as there used to be but it's a
fascinating religion that basically says
it it's kind of like the matrix you know
it says that what you see always you see
isn't real and that it's actually
constructing your mind if you change
your mind and change your body so a lot
about belief and really deep belief that
what you're seeing isn't true this
whatever there's cold that you're
experiencing or and so fright is that
you're you know you're feeling it it's
not
real this is this is a construct of your
mind which is kind of wacky when you
think about it and imagine growing up in
that it's a little weird well I had a at
least one of my grandparents and I don't
think I've ever talked about this was
very much into Christian science and at
the time I mean I was whatever it let's
call it five years old six seven eight
nine I was like oh something science
sure why not like and actually visited
the Christian Science reading room I
guess a these reading rooms in different
cities at one point but never really had
a ton of direct exposure to it and did
go to the doctor lock so I was a very
sick kid growing up did you get really
sick at any point because I've seen at
least one law-and-order
about you know thing they must be maybe
Christian Scientists who have a kid with
say a life-threatening illness or
potentially terminal illness and they
won't let their kid go to the doctor and
then they're in court and it's very
dramatic yeah I did you just dodge all
of the bullets or did you have any any
serious issues well I should say I mean
I did have a very healthy childhood I I
think most Christian Scientists if a kid
breaks his arm they're gonna go to the
doctor I mean it everyone has their own
interpretation based Krishna Sciences
there's there's like a better way to do
this like kind of it's not saying you
can't it technically it says you know
there's a better way to heal something
but culturally it does end up becoming
you can't like that just ends up being
sort of the way people interpret it and
that can be problematic and and if you
don't go to doctors it becomes really
scary to go to doctor it becomes really
frightening that bill diamond that is
some type of master exactly and you told
all these things about how doctors I
mean you know it's it's not it's not no
no I be wrong I mean you know that a lot
of things can happen to you in a
doctor's office people do walk out of
hospital sicker than they got it happens
then they want an you know that happens
but for the most part you know we all
know that hospitals and doctors they
trying to help you but it it's like this
so it is this very difficult thing and
it actually came into play before I
remember I had probably my most serious
disease was I don't remember it because
I was about one and a half
and at the time my parents thought it
was Legionnaires disease I've since
talked to some pediatricians and some
some scientists and tried to figure out
what it was and it's not clear what it
what I had but it was definitely serious
I was definitely having seizures and and
turning colors my eyes are rolling back
in my head it was serious and and my
parents wanted to treat it and Krishna
science and it was it was touch-and-go
and I ended up having what Krishna
science would call a healing and rather
instantaneous healing when my parents my
mom like got to this point where she
she's got panic you know I was really
really bad off and and she you know she
called up a practitioner who these
people who help Krishna scientist sort
of like you know over the phone and sort
of like instructors and guides and she
found a sense of calm and then she
walked back in the room and and I was
better now and now you've talked on his
program about regression to the mean
you know which is when people tend to
get better after they get at their the
worst and it's easily explained well
that way but whatever it was it was a
very powerful story for me growing up it
was like I would think about this a lot
like what this had been like for me is
this little baby and the fact that I
have been saved by God was a very potent
sort of narrative that I had about
myself which which actually leads to the
the book I wrote because it turns out
that's a very powerful thing for and you
mentioned placebos in that same episode
it's a very important part of the
placebo effect is your narrative right
so the placebo effect has been endlessly
fascinating to me I mean what move might
as well go there I mean what was your
first what was your first experience
with the first-hand experience with the
placebo effect well I'm insulting
100,000 people I think where it really
hit me and
actually I met one of the leading
scientists researchers in the country on
placebo this is a former Christian
Scientist we actually won the same
College Christian Science College and
that's how I sort of realized that this
was that there was this connection
between belief and it's called
expectation and this healing and so I
really got into this thing and and I one
of the earlier reporting trips I did was
to the NIH facilities in Bethesda
Maryland have you ever been there I have
not it's like it's like kind of a scary
place this beautiful it amazing it's
like you know basically a miracle
Factory the amazing research that they
do they're like why is it scary well
it's like these big blocky you know sort
of industrial looking brick buildings
with like smoke coming out of the sounds
like East Berlin circa 1970 there's some
really bad movie in which you know like
you know kind of like where that where
dr. Frankenstein has his College you
know I but it's it's actually amazing
place and I went to this corn Penuel lab
woman by the name of Lou Anna coloca and
she's an Italian researcher and she
basically she basically said okay well
I'm gonna put you in a placebo research
trial and she and I didn't know I was
getting into but she hooked up with
these these uh these electrodes to my
hands and she said okay you know we're
gonna electrocute you and we ended up so
we kind of figured out where on my pain
scale was that it was a seven all right
six a pretty powerful shock that that
like it was so powerful I had twitch you
know really really not comfortable and
then they had another one that was like
a one you know and it was his baby a
little pinch and so every time I saw a
green screen
I get the one every time I saw a red
screen I get that seven and and she
purposely sort of like would show me the
red and then she's like way to beat and
then I'll see flinch
yeah because because and this is turns
out this is really important for the
placebo because it's creating
expectation and I'd be like oh my god oh
my god me up you know and you twitch
horrible horrible and she go back and
forth you know
tipping back and forth and you know and
you just come to tread that red screen
and then on the last run it's felt a
little like the the number one had been
I turned up like one it's not like a two
I think that score I was keeping it's
like I'd call it two and then the red is
obviously you know me and like twitching
and then she walks in and she says you
know that was a great job on that last
run I gave you the the high one every
time huh like and it was just you know I
mean it wasn't just that I felt like I
was convincing myself that I had less
pain or like I was like like I had less
pain I was not twitching like I was not
fooling myself I'm not an idiot
you know like it was less and I just
blew my mind no objectively the stimulus
was the same but your nervous system
responded according to your expectations
exactly my basically my brain filled in
the gap my my your brain has
expectations and that doesn't want to be
wrong so when it's wrong it just makes
up the difference and in this case it
released like released
basically a morphine drug that's already
in my brain in them in the end of the
brain and it basically covered up the
pain so I basically got a shot of
morphine so fast that you almost can't
even measure it it happens that quiet
that happens faster than my brain can
realize it's in more pain than expected
because if your brain does not want to
be wrong you know it does not want to be
proven wrong and that's that just blew
me away cuz I kind of in the back of our
head we all think the placebo effect add
as hard as like people just gullible
people who don't want to admit what
really happened but these are real
biochemical reactions that happen and
they are measurable and I was hooked
at that point so then what have been
some of the other of course I'm a human
guinea pig I do all sorts of ill-advised
things to myself trying to ensure I
don't mortally wound myself but what are
some of the other experiments that
you've done or experiences that you've
had involving this personally now the
one you mentioned that I don't have any
context on which was related to a curse
of some type so immediately this is of
interest to me I've spent a good amount
of time places like Brazil and elsewhere
where there's there's quite a bit of
talk about this type of thing so I would
love to just hear the story since I
don't know the first thing about it well
I just the first question and we'll talk
about curses I mean I spent a lot of
time getting burned poked you know
prodded I had almost threw up once
because that nausea is also responsible
to placebos and so soon a naja
experiment you know I've done a lot of
these sort of things but the thing
that's really the most useful for
placebo research is pain and when it
comes to placebos you know really
affects things like you know like
Parkinson's like pain depression anxiety
irritable bowel syndrome basically all
these things are connected by dopamine
and a few other chemicals that seem to
really respond well to placebos and
that's why placebos are so interesting
is because some things have these like
60 70 % responses and other things you
know 10 15 % so there's something going
on there and so because pain you can't
cause depression in a in a laboratory
that I might argue with the current
presidential debate you can you can
cause depression like on command but but
you know it's not something you can
really play with the pain you can so
I've spent a lot of time getting burned
and and poked and all kinds of things
because that's that's what scientists
studying placebo effects study is pain
and and there's actually a lot of
implications for that and when you so an
example of one of these things and I'm
getting to your question no I'm not in a
rush this is not a this is not a
three-minute morning TV show we got time
oh yeah yeah giving so there's so
there's there's a there's a classic
experiment where we're okay so you're a
lot of these things are they're not
conscious these placebo effects and you
talking here and you have the other
episode about how like oh now that I
know that homeopathy isn't real or it
isn't isn't effective it doesn't work on
me anymore well that's not true for
every
actually for a lot of people they can't
help the fact that say homeopathy or a
placebo works in fact you can tell
someone this is a placebo pill it is not
it is inert give it to them and they
will still have a placebo response
what's the explanation for that well
it's a lot of its classical conditioning
you know how many how many times have
you have you ever like taken a Tylenol
and been like oh my God my head hurts oh
my god switch pain take a pound be like
oh god thank you
you know oh I can think has that ever
happen to you it happens to me sure yeah
well title doesn't kick in for like 20
minutes it's so what can you hear you
know what are you experiencing well
that's that is you know and whether or
not it's real or not like that's
basically classical conditioning like
like lob you know you could condition
yourself has experience and so you are
getting drugs they're just drugs that
are already in your head they're not
they're not they're not from the outside
and so for some people it doesn't matter
what you tell them it's subconscious
their brains going to do it whether you
want them to or not and and one of the
people who's studying this she does this
uses phases but they're flat they flash
at you so quickly you can't recognize
them but your brain does and one of
those phases attached to more pain and
the other ones test a less pain and so
you see these phases and your brain goes
more pain and then it responds your your
conscious brain can't tell the
difference between these two phases but
your your unconscious brain sees it
knows what's about to come and this is
again in this case it was burning pain
but it was pain and so that um and
that's what underlies a lot of this
stuff and there's that's some of the
really exciting research women are now
looking at the unconscious nature of
placebo effects and and they may follow
a totally different path they may be
kind of like Google Maps were they like
they kind of overlap on a couple roads
and then they diverge a lot like but
it's it's a whole different thing and
it's really beyond our reach and one of
the big questions that comes up is like
well you know are some people able to
tap into this and other people not but
so I mentioned that you have high pain
you have low pain right well the low
pain is obviously a placebo effect you
know but you're getting the same pain
the same stimulus but your brain
prepares you you know your brain changes
it so your experience is different and
so there's a low pain which is like oh I
don't feel any pain on this one because
I saw certain face and that's the [ __ ]
response but there's also the hi paint
right the higher pain then actually you
should be feeling and your brains like
oh my god this is gonna be very very
painful that's called the nocebo
original season right exactly
and almost every study that looks at
placebos you also have a knows people
you know piece of that equation but no
see bows are actually really hard to
study they're really unethical to study
and in the in the way that we want to
incite you use someone a drug and be
like this is gonna make you really
really sick but this is gonna kill you
or something you can't do that it's IRB
doesn't like to prove that kind of stuff
exactly that that has been tried and it
has not worked out so you know you talk
to me some scientism or like man you
know I understand back in the good old
day was like Cahill and those folks it's
good fast subjects for 40 days
can you guys can't do that with mice for
yeah I don't think you can even exceed
like 72 hours now ah science yeah like
there are these great stories they've
never really able to verify about people
you know with you know being lied told
they were having cigarettes being put on
their backs and all these terrible
things that he could prison inmates you
know to test in the CEPA home basically
you know whatever this thing didn't they
have the main back then but yeah I used
to be able to do that kind stuff so
Missy bows are a little thin on
researching when I was writing this
chapter it was hard to fill it out you
know like you've got so much there's
some really interesting stuff in there
and acebos are definitely more powerful
than placebos if if I if I you know if I
want to train you I will see Bo response
we got to do it a bunch of times so you
really get it down that this is less
pain if I want you have a nocebo
response I just have to tell you this is
gonna hurt this is really gonna hurt get
ready and and your brain your brains
just wired for fear so that's that's
cool but you know I need it more so I
really started getting into these ideas
about superstition and how you can like
really you know cause bad things to
happen in your life just through
expectation to suit belief and real
belief I mean you can't you know you
can't half-ass this theory you really
have to have to feel it and and before
long I came to curses and I've had these
amazing things that have happened to
people in Haiti
there's there's stories of people dying
from being cursed there's just in Haiti
obviously the zombie is his a it's a
well-known phenomenon that isn't fully
understood there's only been three
zombies that have really been documented
and I'm a recent and okay I have to
pause for a second now I saw I think the
Serpent and the rainbow which I which
was I thought was a great movie when I
saw it I haven't seen in probably 15
years but what characterizes a zombie in
the clinical sense at this point um well
unfortunately there haven't been any
that have been recent and the most
they're actually a couple of got written
up in the journal science I know is it
Royal Academy Sciences it's been some
papers and mostly they're debunked but a
zombie is someone who has clearly some
kind of brain damage that causes them to
shuffle and sort of lose contact with
reality and and sort of become a very
difference or a personal way we think of
the big classic zombie they obviously
don't eat brains but um but these this
is a very very old myth that sort of
really tied into the history of Haiti
and no one's you know they've been a
couple documented cases but it's you
know the 30s and you know they don't
really have a lot to tell of it so
there's a couple theories and one of
them in a certain rainbow it talks about
sort of these these this pufferfish
venom that can cause a sort of state of
you know catatonics or a state and the
other idea is part of this thing you see
basically a zombies created when you you
know when you give someone a magic
potion you put them underground you bury
them and then you under a thumb in there
a zombie and one of the theories may be
that there's oxygen deprivation
but there's another sort of idea that
maybe it's just the cumulative power of
everyone's expectations on this is far
now that you do it to yourself
sure I mean speaking in tongues same
thing maybe same ID you know the power
and this is some of the latest research
that's coming out and and keep an eye
out for the National Geographic in
December I've got a story on this
shows that like peer pressure can boost
the placebo effect like beyond anything
that you can imagine this is a hugely
large hugely important part of of the
placebo effect and so the nocebo effect
obviously you know it could be in there
too like other people's expectations can
affect your body in a very real way so
uh I get to this point I'm like you know
I really want to experience like what is
that can i I don't believe in curses you
know that was my problems I don't I
don't believe in these things I believe
in the power of the mind but so how can
you create you know that kind of belief
like I wanted to have that kind of
belief right but you know how it is I'm
sure you probably feeling the same thing
right now
I've always been dying to feel like I'm
going to die from curses one of the
tricks I learned about so I start
getting into curses and I live here in
Mexico so I'm unable to talk to like
I'll brew clothes or witch doctors and
one of the things I learned is you
actually you can only curse them the
only way to curse someone is you have to
tell them they're cursed
you have to do the curse then you can
tell them that curse is only why it
works that I found one woman who's like
no you know like I'm so powerful I'll
just kill them from a distance but
mostly they say you know you have to
tell someone they're cursed
you got to inform them right right and
which is which is such a it's such a
it's such an in my mind this is an osebo
response like this is a very complicated
socially enforced nocebo response and
and I mean just what you just said a
couple minutes ago like you know I've
always want to get cursed like there is
something even you don't believe in
curses there is something off-putting
about being cursed and so I just want to
know if if I cursed myself if if if it
would work if I could psych myself out
so and so I did I hired a guy to curse
me hold on just a second so you have in
Mexico I would imagine a fair number of
Brujo options available how did you
choose this particular person to curse
you well there's actually a market
looked at elected as Yelp reviews
literally it was even it was even more
than that I actually talked to the the
witch doctor market PR people
I so there's actually a market like that
like like there's a lot of like local
markets in Mexico and there's one that
focuses on Brujeria or witch doctors
sort of paraphernalia and they got like
those these weird little like burned
dolls that have evil powers they've got
you know coyote skin I was assuming
these things would all be like secret
and hidden like like some backroom
somewhere where the dark magic is not at
all like this is like this is totally up
front like you want the farmers farmers
market of exactly literally like oh you
want white magic go to this person you
like black magic go to this person and
so it's it's all hot in front and so I
had before I went in I had to actually
you know we're talking to people no you
have to talk to the PR department
there's like this office in the back of
the head oh you weren't kidding I
thought you were joking
there's this office in the back of the
market Moses do guys who sort of hang
out there and they're like oh you know
and I was like I'm here with National
Geographic explanations they were like
okay well you know sign this paper and
yeah of course is their race Gary and
okay there you go and talk to this guy
in this county they're our favorites and
so we did a little we did a little
investigating and sort of found out who
to talk to and they were the same people
that were recommended by the PR people
so we talked to a couple different
people and I sorted chose one of them
was genuinely scary I think and
genuinely really believe that she could
kill people with her curses and you know
she was she was out there and so I'm
like I I didn't actually go with her
because I was afraid she'd find it
insulting you know to to have a curse
put on myself and I went to the other
guy who kind of got a selkie Kenny Pig
okay I guess I guess I can do this like
you know that terrible things can happen
but I said okay and so and he was a lot
more sort of he was also black magic and
knew lots of evil powers but but he was
a little more you know willing to go
with me on it and so I sort shows him
and I walked around for a week and a
half with the curse over
and then what so did so hey did anything
happen and then B did you have to get it
removed like stitches later by the same
guy or what what happened well I mean
you know actually I decided I wasn't
gonna change anything I just want to
live my life normally just do what I
normally would do and so you know like I
went out and just a bottle of scotch
good friend of mine and like walked home
and I was like okay I'm cursed I have to
be careful of cars and stuff like that
but you know I was at that point I
wasn't really you know worried about
curses but the rest the week went by and
I logged every bad thing that happened
to me and and not really much happened
and I started to get kind of cocky and
and and I even went rock climbing I I'm
a rock climber and I went my rock
climbing with some friends over the
weekend and you know and I was leaving I
was going first which is it's not super
dangerous don't it many times before but
it's you know it's a it's not a safe
thing to do but you know and they're all
making fun of me because I was you know
cursed and climbing but you know I got I
said by the timing at the end yeah he's
really gonna an Abbas you know nothing's
really happened I mean I'm kind of
psyching myself out but not really and
then I went back to get the curse
removed and the guy wasn't there he was
gone fishing he's not doing with a
family thing come back next week so I
had another like weekend don't forget
was in June not this last year before
and another weekend and I was fishing be
cursed without we can only guy whatever
nothing happen last weekend though they
have this weekend and on Saturday night
my wife was pregnant at the time started
to feel some some painful pains in her
stomach
and by the next morning had gotten
pretty bad and and we talked the doctor
doctors need to go to the hospital right
now and they were worried that it was
contractions that were starting she was
like four months pregnant so like you
know this contractions lethal at that
point and so we get in a cab and we're
going to the we're going to the hospital
and if only thing that's going through
my head
is the curse and it's never occurred to
her but but I was just panicked that I
had killed my child with a curse and
it's what's interesting is how quickly
your mind goes there how quickly and
it's a it's a logical fallacy that the
Romans called a propter hoc ergo hoc
which is if this then that you know
after this therefore because of this
right exactly that's the correlation
versus causation exactly and it it
usually comes up in the fore in in the
case of something happening and then you
can go backwards in time and find a
cause for it and this is this is the
this is the the home of the cursed is
the continually Kennedy curse right like
a bunch of Kennedys die and very tragic
and in strange ways and you can go back
and you people have looked for causes
you know the going back to Ireland and
one of his ancestors stepping on a fairy
house and you know because once you have
the result then you can go back and find
the cause and and causes seem to be real
at that point and that's exactly what a
man of science I believe in in in logic
and and but my brain went there so fast
when when the [ __ ] hit the fan
like I was I was suddenly convinced that
this is gonna happen and I had I would
never forgive myself if you know and it
would always be in the back of my mind
that I had done this it turned out so we
wind with the hospital and there was a
excruciating couple minutes but it
couldn't find a heartbeat and yeah and
then they did and it turned out the baby
was fine it was some bad tacos from the
day before a good friend of Mines
going-away party and and she was okay
and I
I learned that data that my baby they
went to the sonogram and learned my baby
was a boy and sitting out the room like
laughing with these these these text or
the medical text and I just I just
realized you know what a wonderful day
it had become I was actually Father's
Day yeah that Sunday was my first
Father's Day
and I just I realized that you know this
thing that was a curse it's doesn't
become a blessing and it's such a
construct of what you see now and that
these things only have power when you
give them power and it happens fast so
Sipho to follow up to that did you go
back to the absent witch doctor and get
it removed you know I'm a man of science
but how could it hurt how could I follow
these instructions you had me burn a
candle and do some other solution smoke
on me and the curse is lifted and did
you tell him what happened was he like
yeah I don't want to kill your kid but I
wanted to just shoot a warning shot to
let you know this actually I didn't tell
my weird him out if he thought that he
made because I I see this as being like
this this is proper hoc ergo hoc this is
this is me looking for a cause for
something that have sure but he wouldn't
think that way and I think he would have
I was afraid that he might feel weird
about having about having caused you
know something like that so I didn't I
just said there's some bad things happen
to mention it was very potent my
electric rate of my electric toothbrush
stopped working that way it was a not it
was a practice curse it's a few
questions about placebo right there's a
couple of things that come to mind that
I've always been curious about number
one is well actually I'll get to the
evolutionary question but the the first
is you look at the nocebo effect which I
assume in most cases is an inert subject
a substance in the case of say
ingestible x' or some relatively plain
vanila inactive control of some type but
it's gonna make you nauseous it's gonna
hurt you it's gonna burn you whatever it
might be in the case of placebo we have
the same thing right we might have sugar
pills we might have some type of
relatively inert substance in the case
again of ingestible x' they are there
examples or is there evidence to suggest
that if you have negative expectations
even if you consume a tried-and-true
clinically tested drug for instance that
does work that you can negate the
effects of that medicine if you expect
to die if you expect to get worse I mean
is there any evidence to suggest that
you can interfere with something that
has already been statistically proven to
work with negative but if you if you
have negative expectations absolutely
yeah and that's and that's actually a
misconception about placebos they yes
the easiest way to measure them is with
an inert substance but they exist with
everything like I mentioned the tylenol
like you know that you can have placebos
on top of active drugs and and it's
really a great question like how do you
compare the placebo effect for an inert
drug versus the couple is equal effect
for an active drug because there is one
on top of there and there on the SIBO
effects too and so and this is the thing
this is sort of the thing I keep you
know trying to drive home is like a lot
of this is tied to bedside manner and
how doctors interact with you and you
know if you can be as high as 30% so
like a doctor if he's if he's gonna be a
jerk to you but he's he's throwing a
white 30% of his cure on top of what
he's giving you you know and that that's
a really rough approximation that those
numbers aren't fully worked out yet with
that I mean they're they're a
substantial boost that you can get and
you can also you can erode the
effectiveness of a drug it's been played
with machine some of the earliest
placebo experiments was with the dental
patients and they would they would tell
them they were they were getting they
were either getting painkillers yeah
they also told they're getting something
I would make them worse and injecting
something to make this root canal worse
I think I think they're all recovering
dental patients but but the dentistry
actually played a big role ASIMO's so
yeah there's no question that you can
erode that you can erode an active
treatment with expectation and there's
there's even a bigger question that pain
Sciences are
struggling to understand right now which
is does your brain get into certain
habits do you do do you create these
pathways think of them as like ruts in
the road well you can't get your car out
of the rut you know thinking about pain
and and are there types of pain that are
strictly neurological that feel like you
have pain in your knee but it's actually
in your head and and these are these may
contribute to a huge portion of the
chronic pain our country yeah it's it's
this is something I've explored also for
myself had had chronic back pain for a
very long time and there were some
structure structural Corrections with
specifically gymnastic strength training
with this guy coach coach summer which
helped a lot but it was I also read a
book which I'm blanking on the first
name of the author but I believe it's
Sarno si R and oh and about a half-dozen
of my close friends who had suffered
from chronic back pain credited this
book with fixing their back pain it and
it effectively focuses exclusively on
expectations and the mind and I had
about a week of relief after everything
that Brad it's a go figure
of course nf1 and you know if we're if
we're going along the lines of richard
fineman the first principles that you
must not fool yourself and you're the
easiest person to fool so a lot of
science is trying to prevent
experimenters from fooling themselves
but the the question that I want to ask
in a case like that where it appears to
have at least ultimately it had a
structural component right there there
was an orthopedic issue that I later
fixed but as an intervention the placebo
or mental training component seemed to
help this is going somewhere
you mentioned Parkinson's earlier mm-hmm
and that Parkinson's seems to respond
well to placebo and I'm sure it's not
across all patients but at least a
meaningful percentage and I've read that
Alzheimer's on the flip side does not I
don't know if that's accurate but okay
so so if that's accurate
what is the plausible explanation or
mechanism by which one improves and the
other does not and
of course the experimental designs I'm
sure different but I have both
Parkinson's and Alzheimer's on both
sides of my family so this is a very
personal question for me right and
there's there I was speaking with
someone who's also been on the podcast
Peter tee recently and we were talking
about Alzheimer's disease and he's like
well you know once something is really
denatured yes once the egg turns white
I'm not sure you can reverse it but so
it's it may be a preventative game but
how does Parkinson's differ is it
because it's mediated by
neurotransmitters and you can somehow
rig that game with an expectation long
question I know but how would you how do
you think about the difference between
efficacy of placebo effect in Paul in
Parkinson's versus Alzheimer's it's a
great question it's a really great
question yeah there is there is one one
answer one word answer and that's
dopamine
you know Parkinson's is for those who
don't know it's it's a it's a it's a
deficiency and and usually caused by
usually goes down to substantia [ __ ]
and your brain it's a part that produces
this dopamine and monitors the systems
that that it's it's a deficiency in this
in this in this chemical no this is
chemical not only does it it affects
your movement which is why Parkinson's
patients tend to shake it but it also
affects reward systems it's very much in
tune with rewards that you have jolted
dopamine you know when someone says hey
you just won a million dollars you
jolted dopamine it tends to feel good
and then the down root the downstream
the things that it triggers also make
you feel good it's all around a positive
chemical that that is related to reward
so what is placebo if not reward and
expectation is an expectation of reward
so basically it just so happens that
Parkinson's is is is mediated by a
chemical that happens to be really
important in placebos and that that's
the only answer that I could give you
right now is that it just so happens to
be the right chemical that has it
affects your movement but it also has
this other role
and because of that and that happens a
lot of these different chemicals like
CCK which is a chemical that affects the
nocebo response and it also affects your
stomach and so you know irritable bowel
syndrome and maybe one of the reasons
why your bowel syndrome responds so well
the C buzz but that's and that that
simple fact it plays a huge role and
dopamine's this one is big big chemicals
in your brain it has its it has its
fingers and everything so and and there
is not a a mechanism like that in
Alzheimer's that that leads that lends
itself to a placebo does not say the
placebo doesn't exist in all flavors but
it's much easier to explain with like
statistical explanations like your your
progression of the mean and it it also
may damage the fundamental parts of your
brain that that you need in order to
have it to exist the plus the results or
a to exert the placebo effect upon
oneself that same argument has been made
for autism it's definitely not settled I
have lately seen some some really
interesting studies and autism and
placebos and I know a couple of the top
scientists are turning their attention
to it right now
and but people have often said that for
years that that autism is the same way
but if there is a degenerative element
to Parkinson's that that - is not it's
not like you know Alzheimer's but it's
there was a degenerative but what's
amazing is the placebo effect can almost
I've seen it almost reversed that I mean
it's amazing
and as you got a sure where that
dopamine is coming from but I have seen
people and in the book and also in the
in the story come in at December I
talked about a gentleman who was really
struggling ten years and today he just
climbed Half Dome this year so with
Parkinson's with Parkinson's now so this
this I guess begs the question and there
may not be I don't expect him a miracle
answer to this but placebo effect most
people would think of as being tricked
or tricking oneself right so if you
wanted to proactively use the placebo
effect
and you have a parent or grandparent
with Parkinson's and you wanted to help
them or they wanted to help themselves
what do you do well first of all I think
it's very important Fineman and all
these other folks who say you can't
deceive yourself as a scientist it's
very important as a patient throw it out
the window man right deceive away you
you obviously want to be careful I mean
that's a sort of that the $64,000
question right like that's what everyone
wants to know it's like how can I use
this and and the answer that I've come
up with from a lifetime in Christian
Scientist and Christian Science in the
one you're studying this this we already
do there's a lot of options out there
for study for using placebos and and
it's different for everyone some people
you know it's a sum product you buy it's
you know it's a you know it could be
it's interesting if you look at Posse
Bo's across different cultures in France
suppository placebos work better than
normal placebos that's used let's draw
own conclusions in in Britain it you
know foul-tasting ones work better and
in in in Parkinson's patients actually
I've seen studies that that show that if
you take a pill it's let's see I think
you get about maybe you know average of
15% more movement more mobility and if
you get a surgery a fake surgery it's
like 25 right am surgery research is so
fascinating I mean just get people
listening you have never looked at this
stuff do some googling around sham
surgeries sham surgery experiments and
you find people who have I mean
legitimate structural fuck-ups in their
knees who get fake surgeries where they
get opened up and they're under general
anesthesia so they're knocked out and
then they wake up it's sutured together
and they're like yeah doc my feet feels
so much better even months later it's
fascinating
what's with hilarious about those and
that these are very common in in placebo
and I'm sorry in Parkinson's research
and what partisans researcher told me
that the greatest the greatest
breakthrough and Parkinson's research
has been the sham surgeries but they you
know when you do
surgery's the doctors you know they
don't know that doing the real one of
the or the sham until until a moment of
and they have to um you know they get
the card and says now this is a real one
and then they have to actually sit and
wait for the entire surgery to be over
for Sam surgery because you can't walk
out of the room early you know and have
the patient's family out there watching
you come out after five minutes you know
to go to go clay you know candy crush
something like that like you have to sit
in there surgery ever huge success guys
go get a sandwich it's gonna be a while
before he wakes up exactly that so like
you you know they and they've thought
these things through because in today's
connected age you know these patients
find each other and they compare they
compare stories and they can unblind at
study if you figure out that you're your
doctor walked out of your surgery five
minutes after it started so it's really
tricky and and I've sat in on some of
these these kinds of surgeries and and
and it is and Parkinson's it is it is
stunning what what can happen with with
he say so so yeah I was saying across
different people like there's different
things that resonate with different
people maybe it's like you know
space-age technology maybe it's ancient
mysticism there's lots of different ways
that you can get in touch with your
expectations but the thing is is this is
not hope this is belief this and this is
the thing in Christmas science that I
remember growing up is that people don't
say God will heal me people say God
already healed me I just can't see it
yet and that's a very different things
right I mean very different things
expectation is triggered by certainty
you know by a certain level certain you
know it's a great questions to it like
whether it's the same for everybody
whether certain people are just talented
with their with their own expectation
but there's you know you really have to
believe and how do you manufacture that
though if for instance and I'm not
saying because we're I think we all
overestimate how logical we are in all
aspects of our lives or many of us do
but if you've tried to train yourself to
be hyper rational how do you do that you
just need to become so desperate that
you want something to work so your
condition has to
kind of reach a point of being
particularly bad or is there another is
there another approach because I know a
lot of scientists and if I were trying
to say hey like you have this condition
you can't seem to figure it out you
should go try acupuncture and they'd be
like looked at the data not compelling
right this is if you if you want to like
really make a doctor or scientist
uncomfortable asking this question
studies this no it doesn't I mean
desperation the problem with desperation
is it it and in my book I like you know
three rules of ways not to hurt yourself
and and and and one and these these can
be dangerous these are life-threatening
you know these are life-threatening
issues and we all know stories about
people who have relied on on placebo
treatments that have been died from say
cancer so desperation is not a it's not
a great word when I think about these
things it can be fun though we can be
sort of an exploration and and sort of
looking in your own mind things that
might be plausible and one of my rules I
you know I say don't you know don't
don't die I don't hurt yourself and the
second one is don't go broke you know
you have to be careful that like you
know in order to create expectation you
shouldn't need to spend two thousand
dollars a month you know on something
and and so there's there's this it's a
very tricky and I don't hurt the planet
right or don't that's that's the third
one yeah and and I know I read a little
snippet about this which is like don't
use endangered animals and people might
be like what and Asia analysts like yet
don't go to Chinatown and buy like black
bear gallbladder extract because that's
why there are these horrifying I've seen
video of this you know farms in China
they look like concentration camps where
they have bears and tigers their entire
facilities like dozens of tigers hooked
up to basically these some of extraction
machines it's it's really terrible it's
it's not worth it you know there are
other ways for shark fin soup all that
[ __ ] yeah the story is like she's
more Kandra for sharks but it's just but
all these things they there are
other there other ways to engage your
expectation there are other ways to
create a placebo response and and you
know some nice placebo responses some
there is growing evidence and I I'm
having a hard time believing it's not
true that some of these things can
become permanent you can and you've
talked a lot about rewiring your brain
some of the you know relief can you know
that comes from belief can be permanent
I've certainly seen it as krishna sion
is growing up and and the trick is sort
of finding the thing that that does it
for you and and doesn't cause damage to
you or others you know and there are
lots of options like drink your own
urine like go for it like you know
there's lots of different ways you know
whatever resonates for you these things
it's it's a it's a you know it's a it's
a delicate game and maybe you have to
experiment a lot of things and there are
some people out there who simply it
won't work and that's i think that's
really great an interesting research
going on it again with dopamine into um
into genetics and the genetics of
placebo and and there are some people
who it seems just don't respond and and
they're just gonna be out a lot like
hypnosis right i mean very much related
probably very much it's not as stable
hypnosis tends to be stable over time
and and placebo tends change in day to
day but because your opinions change
always things change but it does look
like there are some people that if you
exclude them and it doesn't really work
on a yet on an individual basis but if
you take a thousand people and you look
at their genetics you can you can take
up a 300 or any most likely to respond
and and it looks like it's like we might
be onto something you know offhand what
the markers are what the snips are yes
the the most the most effective one so
far and there's about 30 that have been
found but the most effective and there's
another money a piece on this right now
is comped its yeah it's the big clap is
it poorly titled warrior warrior gene
but it's it's it's involved with a with
an enzyme that eats dopamine so if you
have it a very active enzyme you have a
lot less dopamine you've got a lot more
efficient system that takes away like
dopamine and
if you have a lazy one you got a lot of
extra dopamine laying around and those
people tend to respond to placebos at a
higher rate people who have more
dopamine laying around extra dopamine
laying around they also there's also
some personality and I'm sure you're
familiar this is a generalizable
personality differences between people
who are there called mech nets versus
the valve valves
this is a classic Mendelian sort of
breakdown of like you know you got the
met Mets the valve valves and the vowel
Mets and there's 50% 25% 25% imaginal
box a little the old Peapod thing anyway
I'm getting that no I love it I love it
way like which which one of those
responds best to Percy was the met Mets
we met that's it looks like there's some
research at Harvard and it's been it's
been it's been backed up in some some
ways that have been published and some
that haven't been published that it's
super-new but it's it's really exciting
and it's it's I personally am at Val I'm
I'm a I'm a mix so I'm the least
interesting 2/3 because I'm somewhere in
the middle and I've got some lazy ones
like thank God you could have died from
your curse I know right it would be here
I don't have you done have you done yeah
I'm sure you've done 23andme right Tim
yeah I've had my five had my full genome
sequence but I don't know if I'm Amit
met Val Val or met though I do not know
that piece it's a great I mean it's
great and there's a few others I
basically am I think the scientists who
I talk to called me a let's say I think
I was sort of a mix like we're all
across the board like I didn't have
anything that was that except for one I
have the coding on the on the receptor
for for opioids in my brain is a little
hungrier it attaches no no recreational
heroin for you then yeah it is your eyes
it's related to addiction do you have to
be careful so and that that all people
who are you know in you see this is it
what's interesting about this is like
these different chemicals in your brain
would let see Bose start working with or
against each other right cuz it says now
you got a big mix and they're all you
know making noise and so that's one of
the reasons why this is probably so hard
to figure out because it's not once a
what
their conditions that people might
recognize like IBS you mentioned really
I think CCK pain Parkinson's what other
conditions Racine to respond well to
placebo based on the data depression
anxiety nausea and obviously addiction
is one that seems to be in this game a
lot of these things related to dopamine
or opioids in internal opioids with with
endorphins and there's a there's um you
know something like and there's a couple
and I've struggled to find really good
examples of especially low responders
but OCD seems to be a pretty low
responder to to and you also mentioned
Alzheimer's and B Lois ponder steve-o's
what if somebody wanted to make a
placebo pill as effective as possible so
I've read bigger pills versus smaller
anything else colors any other form
factor anything that comes to mind or my
are you French as much as I love
suppositories I don't know maybe that
reflects some some French blood I'd have
to look at yeah easy as the best placebo
or be inactive placebo and that's I make
you look that that's what that's what
acupuncture is an active placebo is a
placebo that is inert but causes
something happen your body the most
easiest one is is tingling and like
niacin which is why so many bunk
supplements include niacin or something
called beta alanine because it caused
off the skin flushing and people like
something's happening and that oh yeah
yeah it's very common practice that's
great
no I have to look that up I turn off all
my computer so this interview I'm going
to remember that but yeah that's exactly
what and and there's actually a lot of
if you really want to get into this I
see a lot of debate around the there is
no true placebo because they used to be
sugar pills and and sometimes they use
you know do a type of like busy corn or
you know that it's not clear what a rice
it's not clear if you're allergic to
something like rice you know you can I
guess not a placebo is gonna affect you
so there is no like real true placebo
so it's really hard to create a true
active we'll see but something that's
completely inert except for one effect
like your fingers tingling but in in as
much as we can do that we'd have created
some some interesting placebos that that
make your fingers tingle and you're like
oh my god something's happening and then
whatever expectation you have gets
boosted and that's a very that's a very
potent way to enhance the placebo effect
that's why pharmaceutical companies
don't use activist Abbas because if they
did they'd never be able to they'd never
been with clear any drugs to the FDA
yeah well they might not get the results
they want either hearsay yeah yeah
there's there's some that's for a
separate episode yeah but there are some
really interesting approaches that
companies take to ensure they get the
results they want it's like and what if
you run ten studies and you fund them
all and then you only submit two well
that could be interesting I know we
don't have a ton of time left but I
wanted to mention a couple of things the
first is uh spending some time with a
friend of mine who's former surgeon MD
brilliant guy and he was talking about
how he is an end of one tried to use
placebo control which is very
interesting so he would and of course he
could have sort of experimenter blinded
this with having say his wife do this
for him which you did in a few cases but
he would put these pills whether they
were or capsules whatever they might be
and he would encapsulate placebos right
so he would actually put something
relatively inert like a sugar or fill in
the blank rice flour or whatever in do
these capsules and wrap them in tin foil
and a number of them and he would keep
track or his is uh his wife would keep
track of which were placebo in which
were active and then look at the results
over time it's a lot of work especially
if you're gonna really try to make it
defensible but I guess what I'm
wondering is how have you used all the
all the things you've learned and been
exposed to how do you currently use that
in your life or how do you plan to well
let me let me just say if there's anyone
who has access to placebo pills
especially different colors and shapes
give me a call because I would love it's
actually hard to get ahold of most most
most research institutions from have
their own little recipe and and you can
buy them online but I can tell what's in
those and and you know so so I would
love to and when my plans for this book
was to was to be taking tons of placebo
pills and I haven't been able to do that
so your friend is amazing I love to hear
what he came up with one of them I'll
tell you is that he actually got Pez and
caught them into the shape same color of
the tablets he was taking I mean that's
also I mean you have to kind of be like
a I can like a necklace craftsman to
make that work but and once you spend
that much time looking at this thing are
you really not gonna recognize it yeah
but and also Pez is not a triple C book
with sugar is is you know it's a
stimulant a little bit and and so it
could also be sort of an active placebo
of its own sort so yeah that's that's I
would love to do that and I'd love to
have someone like give me the hook up
for like like you said it colors and
size and shapes have a big big role
playing or in function colors have you
seen in experiments function better than
others yellow yellow works well for
depression that's been that's been
pretty well-established larger tends to
work well better than smaller up to a
certain size and then just gets
uncomfortable then you have to just use
it as a suppository so and there's been
a few other ones that I've seen like
usually based around marketing so like
you know something looks like advil and
that's hard to diamond shaped and blue
something like that that's right there's
I have a whole bit about baggy start on
viagra but
like the other one is gelcaps versus
versus this normal sort of white pills
and I've seen some very small studies
are mixed on that one but it's very
personal it's a very personal experience
it's hard to lump groups of people into
but you know into what they like but and
that's part of the fun fun or whatever
of this process for me I am much more
comfortable with the idea that we are
suggestible this is real this is this is
who we are this is and this is a cross I
mean presents project I went to China I
mean my photographer went to the jungles
of Peru and the highlands of Peru and
everyone one followed pilgrims in Europe
and and you know this is who we are
this this is you almost don't have to
try like we do this well that was and
that was gonna be my evolutionary point
like maybe it's a vestigial dead end of
some type but otherwise I mean there is
a there's a there's a role at this place
I mean this is a this is something
across cultures that we've evolved to
retain for some reason no question no
question and we're not alone I mean you
know animals you can get placebo
responses and animals you can you can
even have immune placebo responses you
could program in rats you can train them
to have immune responses basically the
same kind of response you'd have if
you're getting a organ donated and you
need to cut your moon response down you
can do that through expectation in rats
I don't think it's been done in humans
is probably gonna be once again some
some ethical issues that one but but you
you so this is this is fundamental to
who we are and there's a great
evolutionary reason why this might be
one can easily imagine that having if
you imagine sort of a group of people
you know fending for themselves having
some members of that group being able to
be you know very clear-eyed very
matter-of-fact not influenced by by
suggestion at all might have you know
some benefits for the group and then
having other people who are more
suggestible but able to
go out after an injury you know after he
started healing themselves their own
expectation but blowing smoke in their
face and then feeling better and being
more more responsive to healing could
definitely have also a benefit for that
community that community being a you
know a genetic population and there
being a good reason to have both of
those elements in different degrees in a
community you know evolution is all
about diversity genetic diversity and
and it it makes a lot of sense to me why
we would be programmed this way and if
you're gonna choose one you want to be
the second one you want to be able to to
heal yourself meet yeah like that's what
I did something I take away from this is
like I think going in I think I would
prefer to be the first one but coming
out of this research man the second one
has a lot of options available to them
they got a lot of different ways that
they can harness their own you know and
chronic pain sucks and if you have extra
tools to deal with chronic pain use them
and you know and I think that's that's
it's a valuable thing to have mm-hmm
yeah it's it's such a fascinating topic
and we could talk for hours about your
your adventures in Mexican fishing
villages and great with white sharks and
that'll have to be another time but Eric
where can people find more about of
course the book suggestible you more
about you where can they say hello on
the web or social or anywhere else sure
so suggestible you calm is the the books
website you can you can read about
upcoming events I'm going to be
traveling in in November and then again
in January I'll be in the Bay Area and
New York Boston you know and if anyone
has any events that they'd you know like
to hear more about this kind of stuff
and I'm happy to try what I love sharing
stuff this stuff is so much fun you can
also check out my old my other work at
Eric mance calm and there's like you
said you know spend some time and you
know ancient Mayan temples of chase
sharks have had a weird couple years and
and then if you want to say hi to me i'm
on twitter at at it's with a k eric with
the k yeah okay and for everybody
listening of course in the show notes I
will link to everything as always so we
will have links to everything that Eric
just mentioned as well as any resources
that might have come up in the
conversation Eric thank you so much for
taking the time this has been a em and
to everybody listening as always and
until next time thank you for taking the
time to tune in to the Tim Ferriss show
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek comm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
99designs when your business needs a
logo website business card thumbnail any
other design I recommend checking out 99
designs I use them myself I've used them
for many years I use them to create book
cover prototypes for the 4-hour body
which went on to becoming number one
York Times best seller I've also used
them for banner ads illustrations and
much more with 99 designs you get a
variety of original designs from
designers around the world give your
feedback and then pick your favorite
your happiness is guaranteed so check
out some of my competitions and designs
and some of
your competitions and designs from
fellow Tim Farriss show listeners at
99designs calm forward-slash Tim and
right now you can get a free and $99
upgrade on your first design so check it
out 99 designs dot-com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by wealth
front and this is a very unique sponsor
wealth front is a massively disruptive
in a good way set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront dot-com forward
slash Tim take the risk assessment quiz
which only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why
the value of wealth front is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than ten asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealth front as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront com
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on this
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different
don't use wealthfront yet because I'm
not allowed to here's the deal they
wanted to sponsor this podcast but
because of SEC regulations companies
that invest your money are not allowed
to use client testimonials so I couldn't
be a user and have them on the podcast
but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get fifteen thousand
dollars managed for free if you decide
to open an account but just start with
seeing the portfolio that they would
suggest for you take two minutes fill
out their questionnaire at wealthfront
dot-com forward slash Tim it's fast it's
free there's no downside that I can
think of